The first thing you might do with a garter
bar is to remove stitches
from the machine and rehang them.
I've knit a bit
of stockinette with weight.
Having weight on the
knitting is important.
I've pulled the needles all the way out
and make sure all the latches are open.
Position the garter bar over the needles.
The hooks of the needles
will go in the slots.
Gently pull the stitches off
the needles onto the bar.
As you pull the stitches,
the latches will close and that stitch
will slip right onto the garter bar.
Now, you'll be nervous the first time you
do this, but with practice,
it gets easier.
Push the stitches all the way
to the back of the bar,
and then tilt the bar up,
releasing it from the hooks,
and remove the knitting from the machine.
At this point, you could set the work
aside or move the entire piece,
working increases and decreases,
returning the stitches to the needles.
To rehang the stitches,
make sure the latches are open and put
the slots of the bar in the
hooks of the needles again.
Slide the stitches back onto the needles.
If you have a needle stopper,
it can secure the needles and make
it easier to rehang the stitches.
The second way you can use a garter bar is
to remove the knitting from the machine,
turn it around, rehang the stitches,
and knit a row. Adding purl stitches.
Although it's not practical to knit
the equivalent of garter stitch this way,
but just for a few rows,
this could be a real time saver over
scrapping off or manually
reforming stitches.
Unlike the vintage style of garter bar
that has hills and valleys,
the KhrisKrafter's style is
much more straightforward.
Let's explore RTR, remove, turn,
and rehang with this style of garter bar.
I have a bit of knitting on the machine
and I want to add a garter ridge,
maybe for an accent or a turning row.
I have weight on the knitting.
Now, this is important.
I'll stop knitting with
the carriage on the right.
First, I like to remove the working yarn
from the yarn feeder of the carriage.
Now, if you forget to do this, no problem.
I just like to make it a habit.
I'll position the garter bar over
the needles, putting the hooks
in the slots of the bar.
Notice that the perl side or the wrong or
the private side of the knitting
is facing me right now.
I'll slip the stitches to the bar and push
them all the way to the back of the bar.
As you remove the stitches,
use the bar to open the latches.
Once your knitting is off the machine,
pass your carriage to the opposite side
of the needle bed so the working
yarn is in position to knit.
Again, confirm that all
the latches are open.
With the stitches pushed to the back
of the bar, before you turn and rehang
the work, hook, notice
that there are little openings.
We'll insert the hooks of the needles
in these openings to rehang the stitches.
Now, turn the bar and your knitting
so the knit side is facing.
To rehang the stitches, lay the bar flat,
positioning the hooks in those openings.
Rotate the bar down and you can see
that the hooks are catching the stitches.
If a latch is closed,
it's going to prevent the hooks
from picking up that stitch.
Pull down to slip the garter bar out
of the stitches and remove it completely.
Check to see if any stitches have split or
are not in the hooks,
and use a transfer tool
to manually repair them.
Next, push the work back and knit a row.
Notice the purl bumps facing you.
To complete a garter row, we'll repeat
the steps and turn the work again.
Remove the knitting from the machine,
turn the bar and the knitting,
and re-hang it on the machine.
This time, when I re-hung my work,
I remembered to use the needle stopper.
If you have one, it can be really helpful.
Once the stitches are back on the machine,
knit a few rows and admire
your single garter ridge.